a toast that was to take months of his
premiership a prime minister found to
have broken the law and perhaps the
trust of his party and public too an
excoriating report full of damning
detail grim reading then for this pm
at the heart of his government it said
there were failures of leadership and
judgment an inappropriate and excessive
consumption of alcohol a lack of respect
for cleaning and security staff and
private messages between staff joking
they'd got away with it
out of the bunker to face the noise
heading to parliament to make yet
another apology i want to begin today by
renewing my apology to the house to the
whole country and i also want to say mr
speaker above all that i take full
responsibility for everything that took
place on my watch but this a qualified
apology a pm still on the defense
insisted the events he attended were for
the purposes of work i'm happy to set on
the record now
that when i said i came to this house
and said
in all sincerity that the rules and
guidance have been followed
at all times it was what i believed to
be true
but the labour leader himself the
subject of a police investigation
clear-eyed
that report lays bare the rot that under
this prime minister has spread in number
10
and it provides definitive proof
of how those within the building
treated the sacrifices of the british
people
with utter contempt
even those mps on his own benches which
at times weren't particularly full not
convinced i made my point and my
position very clear to the prime
minister he does not have my support but
a question i humbly put to my colleagues
is are you willing
day in and day out to defend this
behavior publicly
can we continue to govern without
distraction given the erosion of the
trust with the british people and can we
win the general election on this current
trajectory not what he wanted to hear
but bullish still
and after attempts to convince
parliamentarians next for the press and
the public and it didn't get much easier
vomit drunken altercations security
staff being treated with contempt
cleaners having to mop up red wine
sue gray's is shaming dossier really
isn't it of what's meant to be the place
the heart of government that sets the
standards of our country
and it's your culture under your
leadership
did you never think about resigning a
poll out today just out says three in
five britons think you should beth i of
course i understand uh why people are
um uh indignant and and
i
and why people have been angry at what
uh what took place i hear you i i
understand you uh but i i really feel
it's my job to
to to get on was there any point you
thought about it though because during
any of it did you ever think this why
are only you allowed to come back
some special position
okay forgive me
and no matter how uh bitter and painful
the conclusions of this may be and they
are uh and no matter how humbling they
are i've i i've got to
keep moving forward and the government's
got to keep moving we are
but moving forward will depend on the
support of his mps and another one today
called on the prime minister to resign
taking the total to 16 and this one
doesn't sound far off either is he still
the vote winner you
need for the conservative party i am
struck today by a number of colleagues
who are
really concerned that it's almost
impossible
for the prime minister to say at one
stage i i want to move on and the public
wants to move on and yet we haven't
regained the public trust i'm not sure
we can
and i think there are a lot of
colleagues today but actually realizing
that unless something happens
we may not be able to win the next
general election do you think he should
resign
i think the prime minister i think the
prime minister doesn't enjoy the trust
of a lot of the british people and i
think he's going to reflect on that very
carefully
tonight the pm on his way back to
downing street having addressed a group
of his backbenchers he wants to move on
the jury out on whether in the end
they'll let him beth rigby sky news
westminster